so Jeffrey Donaldson the dup won't
restore power sharing and the UK
government doesn't seem to know if it
wants an election in Northern Ireland or
not surely the people of Northern
Ireland deserve better governance than
this well indeed we want to see
Stormwind restored as soon as possible
and I say I don't think an election
takes us closer to a solution so why not
use the next few weeks to double down on
getting either a negotiated solution
with the European Union or bringing
forward the legislation in Parliament
that will resolve the issues around the
North Island protocol but given that
we're now six months past the Assembly
Election there is no devolved government
is the Northern Ireland secretary not
legislatively obliged to call an
election well let's look what has
happened in those six months since the
Assembly Election we've had three prime
ministers Westminster at times has been
in chaos there's been little focus on
getting a solution to the protocol the
talks with the EU only started again a
couple of weeks ago and even then only
at a technical level know that a
political level how is it easier to
resolve the problems around the protocol
outside of the power sharing government
rather than inside working together to
find a solution well of course David we
tried that for over two years we tried
to get a solution on the protocol and we
worked with the other parties we pressed
the government to take action and the EU
simply said no there will be no
renegotiation of the protocol and it
reached a point where our ministers in
Stormwind were required to impose
measures on the people of Northern
Ireland as a result of the protocol that
every day every single day was harming
our economy our businesses driving up
the cost of living for households
um you know 25 tariffs on steel products
coming from Birmingham to Belfast that
is ridiculous you say the EU says no the
dup says no to power sharing says no to
the protocol said no to Theresa May A's
backstop option are you at the point
where the dup regrets saying yes to
brexit in the first place well we say
yes to power sharing but it has to be on
the basis of mutual respect it has to be
on the basis of adhering to the
principles of the Belfast or Good Friday
agreement and at the heart of that
agreement is that Northern Ireland is
part of the United Kingdom that was even
accepted by the Irish government who
changed their constitution to recognize
Northern Ireland as part of the UK the
protocol has cut across that we never
supported that the protocol we made
clear it would harm Northern Ireland it
would create instability and so it has
and I welcome the commitment now of the
EU to negotiate a new solution I welcome
the fact that the EU is now at the
negotiating table why is that David it's
because of the pressure we have put on
it's because of the steps the dup has
taken that finally we're getting a
negotiation a proper negotiation on
finding a solution to this problem
that's what I've asked for and now we
need to see that solution coming forward
and frankly the sooner the better is
Rishi sunak the dup's worst nightmare
because he clearly doesn't want to trade
war with the EU and therefore isn't
going to tear up the protocol well look
I do want to trade war with the EU I
want to trade with the EU but I
fundamentally want the ability to trade
within my own country and that is what
the protocol denies us and look whoever
is the prime minister in Westminster I
have to work with them I have to work
with the government and I will I am
absolutely committed every single day to
working to find this solution and I will
work with Rishi sunak to get that
solution and all I ask of the government
is that the objectives that they have
outlined in the Northern Ireland
protocol bill which is currently before
parliament are the objectives that they
pursue in the negotiations Liz truss
gave us that commitment Rishi sunak has
also stated that he wants to achieve the
same objectives so let's get on with it
let's get this Solution that's see the
negotiations and the tempo of those
negotiations increased so that we get to
an outcome that unionists can support
the refusal to restore power sharing
isn't really about the protocol or is it
about the fact that Shin fein's Michelle
O'Neill is on course to become the first
nationalist first Minister well look my
party is the Democratic unionist party
that means first of all we accept the
outcome of the election but let's not
forget David I withdrew my ministers
from the executive or the first Minister
back in February well before the
election I signaled way back in
September last year the the actions that
we would take if a solution was not
found on the protocol so this is not to
do with who is the first or Deputy first
Minister this is about the second part
of what my party stands for the Union
it is about unionists feeling that they
are they have been made second-class
citizens as a result of a protocol that
diminishes and undermines our place in
the United Kingdom that's what we need
to resolve and I'm focused on getting a
solution and this when we get that
solution I am absolutely clear the dup
will be back in government doing our bit
to build a better future for everyone in
Northern Ireland every time unionism has
pulled out of government it has ended up
in a worse situation if there is no deal
to restore power sharing at the end of
all of this what is the alternative
surely we can't just be looking at a
return to direct rule from Westminster
after all these years I'm not prepared
to accept failure I'm going to work for
Success I'm going to work for a solution
and every single day I'm going to be at
Westminster or at storm or in Brussels
wherever I need to be to press for that
solution because we need that for
Northern Ireland we need stability we've
got got a cost of living crisis there
are many issues we need to be addressing
I want to see a fully functioning
devolved government again in Northern
Ireland so that's what I'm working
towards David I'm not prepared to accept
and that there won't be an outcome to
this
um I've often said before and I say it
again when I look at the last 25 years
in Northern Ireland the mountains we
have climbed to build peace and
stability are far higher than the
mountains in front of us but given that
unionism no longer holds sway to the
extent it once did is joint Authority
London and Dublin governing Northern
Ireland not a realistic possibility well
it is certainly not part of the Belfast
or Good Friday agreement the UK
government have made clear joint
Authority is not an option I think joint
Authority and even talk of joint
Authority David I think is reckless I
think it raises tension at a time when
what we all need to do is focus on
getting a solution and Joint Authority
is no solution
you very much